new york police have been tasked with
enforcing social distancing
and a study suggests that at nypd
arrests are racially biased
rt's america's trinity chavez has more
today new york city mayor bill de blasio
facing backlash over the way the nypd
enforces social distancing rules
this comes after several alarming videos
surfaced on social media in recent weeks
showing violent encounters with police
and alleged social distancing violators
specifically in black and brown
communities
this video capturing the moment an
officer waves a taser and repeatedly
strikes a bystander during a social
distancing bust
police watchdogs accusing officers of
using social distancing during the
pandemic
as an excuse to harass people of color
along the lines of stop and frisk
others taking it a step further
criticizing what they call
police officers double standards going
after minorities during this pandemic
but allowing crowds of mainly white park
goers to gather
in large groups
craig schlei the founder of foundation
for red dress told rt
the cop's attitude towards seeing whites
in central park who are massless and
crowded together
are greeted with a smile and hand and
masks but blacks and latinos who are
alleged violators
are greeted with balled up fists to the
face a firm foot up the butt
and tight handcuffs violence prevention
groups across new york
city now stepping in the groups which
are mostly young black and hispanic men
the same demographic that has either
been given summonses or arrested for
offenses related to the coronavirus
pandemic
are known as credible messengers rather
than rely solely on police
they too encourage others to follow
social distancing rules
the mayor announcing today that he is
also enlisting some help
so we will work with 18 care violence
organizations
across 21 neighborhoods of the city and
use
the trust that they have built in
communities the important standing they
have the reach
they have to educate people about the
coronavirus to help people do social
distancing to make sure folks have face
coverings are using them
now the nypd tells me that between march
16th
and may 10th the department has made 125
copen 19 arrests
many of which were response to
complaints and of those arrests
90 of them were either black or hispanic
reporting from home in new york trinity
chavez rt
you